oh my gosh the anticipation has been
building to this we have a new Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice trailer and
what do I think what are my thoughts
it's a little disappointing to be honest
that's not to say this trailer had
nothing I liked in it there were things
in this trailer I liked but the bummer
is everything I liked in this trailer I
already knew I liked everything I didn't
like I already knew I didn't like for
the most part we'll get to the most part
later oh the most part the first of all
this trailer starts out Bruce Wayne and
Clark Kent are kind of bantering back
and forth work oh well your vigilante
and Gotham sucks and Bruce Wayne's like
oh yeah well every time Superman gets a
cat out of a tree your daily planet
writes a puff piece about him so
whatever clowns and I wanted to see
something like that in this trailer and
it's great to have the trailer start out
with something like that it didn't need
to be over a minute long though my god
is one-third the length of the trailer
but hey now we get to see the trailer
and all the cool stuff we like Bruce
Wayne meets Clark Kent I love it I love
bringing people together how are we I
okay I'm gonna be honest with you guys
I'm still not feeling that now I know he
plays Lex Luthor's son he's in a movie
of Batman vs Superman is one in a Lex
Luthor that was just a little less like
that he does have a great line in
response to Lois Lane calling him
psychotic he's like that is a three
syllable word for any thought too big
for little minds I thought that was cool
I liked the line there's a lot of cool
Batman vs. Superman stuff we knew it
would be in here but we've seen it in
the trailers before so I mean you like
seeing it it's like Bruce you're not
gonna win this he's like that son of a
[ __ ] brought the fight to us I'm like
Ruben but at this point the way the
trailer was cut together you already see
you're like this is one of those
trailers that's cut together to
ultimately be a mini movie it's like
they took the movie and compress it into
three minutes and you're like here
I don't like trailers like that I like
trailers that vaguely show us the
characters some of the motivation the
intrigue some bits of dialogue let's go
the force awakens has done it
brilliantly thus far but at this point
this next thing made me think I just I
just saw the entire movie compressed
into three minutes only slides down the
building Wood is this that's right folks
they have to take on the cave troll from
Fellowship of the Ring no seriously at
first I was like what on earth is that
I've already seen pictures like Killer
Croc so I know it's not him holy [ __ ] is
that monstrosity supposed to be doomsday
Gambhir nice
it's the only thing that implies
doomsday to me or the bone sticking out
of the back keep in mind this is not me
assessing that this is doomsday based on
how he resembles doomsday but rather how
he doesn't resemble anything else I had
to do process of elimination on this one
day she's a big face laser at Batman The
Wonder Woman's there and they're all
going to throw down and that's the movie
I mean the trailer guys seriously what
is it with trailers really breaking down
the entire movie forest I imagine
they're still going to be secrets in
this movie some twists and turns here
and there the only thing I saw in this
trailer that gave me a new sensation I
didn't have before was the doomsday
thing that's not necessarily a good
thing I mean how cool would that have
been to see something that resembled
doomsday pop onto the screen when you're
watching the movies you had no idea it
was in here maybe a couple of hits to it
in the trailer so people are like blown
up for them to look up theorizing of
making videos theorizing theorizing but
now everyone's gonna be bitching about
doomsday and how he doesn't look like
doomsday or they're gonna say they love
doomsday I don't know I personally think
he kind of looks like [ __ ] which is
funny because the teaser to this teaser
that they had like the sneak peak they
had a couple days ago actually intrigues
me more than this entire trailer I
didn't talk about the sneak peak thing
because I was like I was fifty seconds
of footage I'll just wait for the
trailer little did I know I would have
had more fun doing a video on the fifty
seconds of footage rather than this
trailer because I could have been
speculating could've been theorizing but
anything's stock button you know what
retrospectively I might go back and
actually do a video on the fifty second
trailer look out for that it might
happen so yeah that's the trailer for
Batman V Superman I personally didn't
think it was a great trailer it shows
you a Batman vs Superman ish things but
there have been some really cool
trailers lately I'm not just talking
about the superhero movies or star wars
you know the big-budget movie some of
the smaller movies there have been some
really cool trailers out there cloaked
with intrigue and mystery this is the
big trailer before the movie comes out
they should have jacked everyone out but
as I stand right now this trailer didn't
really excite me it reinforced what I
was already thinking and feeling I'm
looking forward to Batman and Superman
hating each other it looks like Lex
Luthor is gonna be annoying and it looks
like Wonder Woman was shoehorned into
the end of this movie so you can have a
big fight at the end hi guys so the new
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more